again it is an expression of the
individuality the authentic truth of who
Nick Diaz he is yeah that's why that's
all right yeah we were just talking art
and fight that's a fight this was a
great and he got lived a fight watch a
little bit of this because he just he
just kept the pace he's just refusing
yeah Paul just got too tired too quick
he was he was winging big shots and look
at Nick just that's just left hook
you're talking about yeah this is over
okay it's over there we're done no Nick
won't be done yeah well I mean who knows
may have Paul is in better condition but
this is the end the end is Nick just
battering him it's crazy that he did his
striking contest yeah but he did it with
will he was always a great boxer yeah
but I mean and again where this were
this a metaphor for life like you got
some of the greatest victories ever yeah
it really was
that was that the quintessential Nick
Diaz fight and there are people who
don't like him I love that guy me too
because that's what were what we're
searching for I think is we're trying to
be authentically who we are yeah I think
that's all we're doing that's what Nick
Diaz is whatever the [ __ ] you think he
is he is authentically Nick Diaz no and
and the metaphor to me is Paul Daley is
a wall and you can you can dig under it
or you can go around it or you can trick
somebody to give you a rope or you can
climb it or you can dissemble it and
Nick's like [ __ ] it I'm gonna go through
it I'm gonna go through it yeah and
there are many ways to choose to live
your life and that's how Nick Diaz lives
his [ __ ] life and that's that's
beautiful what sucks is that he hasn't
fought and forever huh I mean he hasn't
fought since the Anderson Silva fight
that's crazy and it's crazy that they
suspended him for marijuana when
Anderson Silva tested positive for
steroids in that fight and he got a
shorter suspension than Nick that's a
reflection that's a cultural leftover
cultural election that's also that Nick
refused to pay the fine because that's
Nick Diaz being authentically Nicolas
yeah yeah you're not getting that money
from me you can admire that like some
some people will look at that and go do
just pay it it'll go this way you say no
fundamentally who I am I cannot do that
yeah I will get negative consequences in
my life but I will be authentic to who I
am but Nick is like 36 now I think how
old is Nick Diaz now 34 he's 34 now so
yeah oh dude his first fight in UFC I
believe he was 20 you know when he
fought Jeremy Jackson like way back in
the day he was 18 you know I mean he's
been around man you know he's been
around so he's still like literally in
its physical prime I mean and this is
crazy considering the fact that I want
to say the Anderson Silva fight was
three years ago yeah yeah I would love
to see him back in there again you know
I don't know got to do what you want to
do though I don't know if he really
truly that's what he wants to do he'll
he'll find a way to do it and if he
doesn't